revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 Rosa Pérez mateu ya está en
nuestro estudio Rosa buena mañana de
viernes finalizamos una semana muy
movida de información yo creo que desde
la guerra en Ucrania no hemos optado a
tener semanas así no Así así bueno Rosa
vamos a hablar de una polémica
declaración de un asesor cercano al
gremin que afirmó que los drones que usa
Rusia para atacar Ucrania efectivamente
son de fabricación iraní algo que Irán
anegado y se ha desligado de esto que
tenemos sobre este tema exactamente lo
que ha sucedido es que una analista de
seguridad cercano al kremlin justo antes
de ser entrevistado por periodistas de
la televisión económica rusa rbk
pensando que tenía el micro cerrado pide
precisamente a los entrevistadores que
no le pregunten por el tema de los
drones porque las autoridades rusas no
quieren admitir admitir que son de
fabricación iraní a pesar de que todo el
mundo no sabe escuchemos este fragmento
Cómo cambiaría el mercado global
preguntemos a un experto en nuestro
estudio rusland director del centro para
análisis estratégicos y tecnologías y
miembros del public country del
Ministerio de defensa de Rusia no
vayamos a crear problemas les pido que
no me pregunten por eso iraníes es la
clásica situación en que no se quiere
mencionar lo evidente todos sabemos que
son iraníes pero las autoridades no lo
reconocen
bienvenido empecemos por cómo la
producción del mercado global
bueno Rosa y también se ve como la
presentadora evidentemente trató de
advertirle de alguna manera montándose
En su declaración de que tenía micrófono
abierto no Exactamente no los temas del
directo que a veces son difíciles de
resolver son difíciles de resolver en
directo puede pasar cualquier cosa y
pues lo que ocurrió en Reino Unido
todavía sigue teniendo repercusiones no
la renuncia de la primera ministra
británica listroso vamos a ver cómo lo
titula la prensa de Reino Unido
exactamente y precisamente una cuestión
que cayó ayer en directo 100% totalmente
bueno tenemos una pequeña selección de
prensa británica de Guardian titula el
amargo final de Herald este medio
escocés señala que la estabilidad en
dawning Street es clave para digamos a
vigilar mantener a raya en cierto modo
el movimiento independentista en Escocia
el financial Times dice tras renuncia
tras 4 cuatro días en el cargo o de San
cita Boris Johnson no voy a volver dice
que ese retorno sería la madre de todos
los regresos bueno y por ya continuar
con la prensa británica pero hacer un
breve cierre digamos a lo que serían los
periódicos vamos con the Times
exactamente qué dice entonces de Times
Rosa pues señala dos puntos de vista un
poco Opuestos por un lado titula
reacción violenta no black-lash contra
Johnson algunos parlamentarios
conservadores consideran que hundiría
definitivamente el partido no una Un
regreso de Boris Johnson mientras que
por otro lado titula que varios donantes
digamos conservadores están ya
subiéndose al carro de este regreso de
Boris Johnson vamos a ver lo que acaba
pasando también que rishizunak que al
que llaman profeta de la fatalidad
asegura que es su momento o copenny more
down es una opción que se plantea como
unidad por otro lado también utiliza
algunos calificativos para señalar la
respuesta internacional a esta dimisión
de listas dice líderes de todo el mundo
observan la situación con preocupación
desprecio y un cierto grado de diversión
creo que bastante bien elegidas digamos
estas palabras también señala que los
italianos se enfadan ante la comparación
de Reino Unido con Italia y es que por
ejemplo di econumes publicó una portada
en que titulaba Welcome to brittalino y
los italianos dicen bueno digamos que
los británicos tienen sus propios
problemas entre otras cosas por el
brexit y para hacer una comparación
también con América Latina también lo
han Comparado con la situación de Perú
también inestabilidad política constante
Si se quiere en ese país no Rosa
exactamente y bueno Muchos británicos en
Twitter y tal comentan Bueno al menos
los italianos pues tienen pasta y Pizza
no los peruanos tienen ceviche nosotros
tenemos que aguantarnos todo esto con
alubias encima de un trozo de pan bueno
bueno pasemos si te parece a la prensa
internacional que también tiene bastante
ingeniosa digamos vamos a empezar
entonces con el estado de minas de
Brasil exactamente que titula listas la
breve y son a muchos los títulos que se
han otorgado a esta primera ministra con
el mando con el mandato más breve
Precisamente en el de las 10 de Downey
Street la estampa por ejemplo de Italia
también la ha concedido el título de
Lady disaster o ABC de España la ha
llamado dama de barro Pues en oposición
a la Dama De Hierro Cómo se conocía
margaret thatcher o al jazeera por
ejemplo eh señalaba falta detrás no como
Falta de confianza por otro lado Los
Ángeles Times dice con otro líder de
puesto los británicos no se sienten tan
Great No pues haciendo este juego de
palabras con Great Britain Pues que por
un lado es grande pero por otro lado
también es estar bien o estar genial y
dice que bueno por otro lado la
vanguardia señalan como este vacío de
poder agrava la crisis no y es que por
un lado el istras era el símbolo de la
crisis Pero por otro lado su ausencia
digamos que todavía aboca más el país a
la incertidumbre La Vanguardia dice la
renuncia detrás como decíamos agrava la
crisis británicas o Lemon crisis inédita
tras la dimisión de listas pero yo creo
Raúl que nada resume tan bien lo que ha
significadodo para Reino Unido digamos
este breve mandato como el vídeo que le
ha hecho la bbc de despedida solo hemos
podido cortar un fragmento Porque no
tenemos tiempo de mostrarlo todo pero
atención a la música porque han elegido
la canción de Rihanna Take abow que
significaría como hacer una promesa o
Pues un voto no veamos este breve
fragmento
[Música]
llegué al cargo En un momento de una
gran inestabilidad política
internacional
quiero aceptar la responsabilidades y
decir que lo siento por los errores que
se han cometido
[Música]
soy una luchadora no una
cobardado
[Música]
he tenido suficiente de gente inepta